if you're trying to avoid the highways
and staying close to home this week odds
are that you were actually out this
weekend trying to get some shopping done
yeah well many big box stores are
offering holiday deals so are locally
owned businesses kate houston live right
here in studio after stopping by a
family-owned bakery that is located in
green valley kate yes our small
businesses like humboldt suites in green
valley are extra busy this week they've
already maxed out their pie orders for
thanksgiving an economic expert at unlv
tells me there's a renewed enthusiasm
for shopping this year especially at
small businesses we are going to be
doing a lot of pies and a bunch of cakes
and stuff so and we are sold out for
that right now over the next few days
the two bakers at humboldt suites will
turn out nearly 150 pumpkin cream and
chocolate cream pies we don't want it
sitting around like our pie sitting
around for two days we feel them that
same day that people are picking them up
and
so everything's nice and fresh tamara
piccolo is the head baker she says due
to the volume of orders they're hoping
to bring on another team member ahead of
christmas and next holiday season we're
doing a lot more orders now but when
coveted it set us back but now we're
coming out of it and things are due are
great jamie schwartz with the unlv
office of economic development says
supporting small businesses is needed
you're supporting your neighbors their
kids go to school with your kids and
they're part of your local ecosystem so
that's good for everyone when looking
for black friday deals schwartz says
there will be more local businesses
offering online discounts than ever
before when they're doing their shopping
and when they're thinking about
giving to their family members maybe you
can simultaneously give to your
community by supporting the community
and buying local
well if you're wanting to shop locally
in person schwartz recommends a few
different areas of town that includes
the arts district in downtown water
street in henderson and the business
corridor in north las vegas